hello folks
how's everybody i hope everybody's doing
fine
a little better than me yes and this is
rational science directly from
frankfurt germany and i just wanted to
say
that the reason i post bone wednesday's
class to today
is that i was in the hospital and um
i thought i had a mild heart attack
and they checked me out they had me
there for
six seven hours and it turns out that
i'm okay
i have no problem with my heart i don't
know why i would have problems with my
heart because
i run every day jog half an hour almost
every day
and they checked my blood my pressure
everything was normal they sent me back
home but it was a little scary i had
some kind of adrenaline flow
near my heart and a woozy feeling so i
didn't know what it was
and talking about near death or being in
limbo between life and death
today's subject matter is schrodinger's
cat
and it turns out that that was the
subject i was considering
that i was going to talk about on
wednesday so well i postponed it to
today
but before i get into schrodinger's good
cat
we're gonna play a little game it's got
to do with extinction
okay and it's called the
game of haves and have-nots
okay the game of the halves and halves
knots
looks something like this okay that's
the board okay
and what this is about is again uh the
arrows just uh indicate time
for most of human history we've been
hunter gatherers
okay i've you've heard me say that
before and i would say
i put 90 but i think we were hunter
gatherers for more than 90 percent
of the of our time and i judge the
beginning of humankind as
you know if we go back in time today uh
who would be
the last person we could still have
viable sex with in other words
reproductive sex
and that would probably be anywhere
between 200 300
000 years ago and so that would be my
starting point for the species
since then 90 percent of the time we
have been
hunter-gatherers about uh
maybe anywhere between uh five
and ten thousand and maybe even fifteen
thousand years ago
uh we went into uh agriculture
first subsistence agriculture taking
care of our own needs
and then eventually moving into
commercial farming
when we built the villages and uh
started becoming more neighborly with
with our neighbors
okay i would say that maybe nine percent
of the time humans have been on earth
again since 200 to 300 000 years ago
um we've been in agriculture that was
the main mode of production
and as you can see only one percent uh
covers the rest
uh we were manufacturers maybe uh
since the uh late 18th century we could
say that's when the
industrial revolution started in some
countries okay especially in europe
and uh that lasted for quite a while
until about
i would say 1979 uh which is
about the time when the bretton woods
accords were uh
also signed which is when we switched
over to
services in other words services in in
some of the
most advanced nations became the
primary mode of production you could say
in other words most people worked
in service and more people worked in
services than they worked in
manufacturing and agriculture and also
gdp a bigger percentage more than 50
percent started being
[Music]
services and from there we just
increased services today uh we've got uh
almost maybe in some of the advanced
countries we have maybe 85
services about 14
manufacturing maybe one percent
agriculture that's how it's divided
but then as i uh said the other day
we've got different kinds of services
and the services that's taken
over in the last 10 years i mean we've
had services now for 40 years
since about 1979 1980 thereabouts
and about 10 years ago a new trend
started
and that's services that do not require
hands
in other words it used to be uh
labor intensive services that's what i'm
going to call it and we started going
into the information business
we're all getting on the internet and
we're leaving behind things like you
know landscaping
building roads maybe um
barbering uh
fast food restaurant any of those you
know so so we stopped doing
or was we're phasing out
things that require people and we're
moving into
things are more abstract information
commercials
uh doing websites for ads that sort of
thing
okay and so this is the big picture okay
and why is this one
pertinent well here's uh
what it's about it's about trade
what can you trade well as far as i'm
concerned there are essentially
three things that you can trade we can
make it a little more complicated have
sub-categories
you can buy land and sell it as well
that sort of thing but
uh these three essentially cover it uh
oh this is the basics this is the
fundamentals okay here
and we have uh labor you can trade labor
you can
trade gadgets things uh
things that have been processed
manufactured things things that we make
okay
inventions that sort of thing tangible
things
which are not food and then you have
food okay
so these are the three three things you
can pray
i'm going to call the people who have
remember this the game of haves and
have-nots
okay the haves are the people who have
gadgets and food okay who have control
over gadgets and food not that you go
out there and buy it now that's not
control control means that you produce
it you distribute it you know
you're in control of food and you're in
control of
uh the televisions the tv sets the
the telephones the cars the
ships all that stuff the people who
actually own
these things or manufacturing these
things which they own it until they
trade it
for web for usually for money okay and
have nots
what do they offer all they have is
their labor all they can do is
trade their labor for something okay so
that's the big picture and here's a
just a little tic tac toe on that okay
you can see how it is you can trade food
for food food for gadget food for labor
uh gadget for food gadget for gadget
gadget for labor and so on
okay so all you got to do is put the x's
there and those are the different
possibilities
in in the gaming model talk about today
okay i hope you you can follow along
don't get lost okay okay let's start
with a little background here
or where am i coming from with this
trade thing okay
here you have uh our beginnings
uh you could call it begin there was a
beginning before this beginning but it
was the same it was hunter gathering
and i think it was like 99 hunting and
maybe almost nothing gathering gathering
probably started
just maybe around the neolithic or be
just slightly before that i don't think
there was that much gathering in the old
days
uh you know paleolithic and so on okay
uh what's the family type it's the clan
it's um group sex
group reproduction every everybody's
fair game
inside the cave okay uh maybe someone
elopes gets out of the cave finds a
little girl out there who also eloped
and they farmed a new clan
that's one way of doing it there there's
different
theories on that okay but essentially it
was the clan okay
uh people you trust you don't trust the
clan on the other side of the river
so cro-magnon kromanon uh he
um he did not trust the fellow on the
other side
they were enemies they were competitors
they had their own lands
the country was the clan okay and uh
so was there any trade well perhaps
within
the clan you can talk about trade you
know there was a division of
labor essentially and you have the men
who
probably made their own tools and
weapons right they hunted
they defended the clan okay that was
their responsibility that's what they
did
and a woman women maybe and this is
again maybe
you'll accuse me of being too macho
centered but
i this is the way i see it i think women
primarily stood at home
stayed at home primarily because you
know they had children they had to take
care of the children they reared them
right
and they probably cooked uh
when clothes came around they probably
helped make those garments while the men
were out there
you know i think a lot of that developed
in those days
and that's just my guess i i i don't
have any proof or any of that okay
that's just the way i imagined it okay
and they probably did some gadgering
okay so they probably gathered nuts
while the men went out there and hunted
some animal
okay food is the only real commodity
okay
but within the clan uh that's the only
time you probably will see
trade because there is no trust
no one trusts anyone in the jungle just
ask any lion
does he trust his neighbor the pride
next door no they're enemies they're
competitors in fact the biggest enemy of
a lion is another lion
certainly it's not a cheetah or a um
a uh what is it a fox or a small animal
you know you just
those are not enemies of the lion the
enemy of a lion is another lion
okay he's the king of the jungle right
okay um uh here uh
then uh we continue we go from uh the
hunter gatherer
and uh stepping over a lot of steps here
okay just
jumping over them okay uh family type
goes to
patriarchy uh maybe in the days of the
greeks which is what i'm
illustrating there okay obviously there
was this phase where
we started doing farming then we again
subsistence to begin with maybe there
was a mixture of hunting in
and agriculture and then eventually it
shifted
more or less into agriculture and left
hunter
and gathering behind okay we don't have
any hunter gathering today almost
okay maybe some tribe out there still
does it
uh in this society this new
arrangement uh the master is the one who
he's the have okay he he is the one who
controls
not only the food but the gadgets he's
the owner of the house the land he's the
owner of everything
okay and uh he also has power of life
and death
over his wife and children okay
he had that kind of power he was the he
was the man
okay long long days
okay we formed of tribes the villages
the uh
cities they evolved they started we had
these city-states at least with the
greeks
even before that you had the persians
they also had cities big city in fact
persepolis
um trade develops uh because what now
you
you trust you form these villages and
somehow trust develops there and because
of trust
trade develops you begin exchanging
things maybe it was goods at first again
maybe it was good for good
in other words a gadget for gadget maybe
it was gadget for food
and at some point in time we started
trading labor for
food one example i've given in the past
is
the story of ruth you can read in the
bible
and ruth worked for food
she traded her labor for barley she was
given this party and she would take it
home in fact she took it to
her mother-in-law because she couldn't
work apparently
and so her work served to
maintain the two women okay they were
both
widows okay uh so we developed trade we
developed trust before we developed
trade right
and we began to trade everything gadgets
food labor the whole
uh works slave he works for food and
you would say close to half the
population in some places in fact i
think in sparta it was even bigger the
helots they were
i think they were a bigger population
than the spartans
but they were slaves they worked the
fields and they were under control
uh but yeah slave works for food
uh he does exchange but it's not a
voluntary exchange
okay and we have the same or similar
situation this gradually change over
time
futilistic uh era we have the serfs
and they don't have much of a choice
either they have to work for food
and part of that labor in other words
part of the
product of that labor goes to maintain
the lord who
protects them you know joe will protect
you
you need protection okay and uh so the
lord is the one who
is the have here right he's the one who
has
and uh the serf the vassal
uh he he doesn't uh have
really he he just
in the case of the surf specifically he
uh
donates his labor he has another choice
okay that is his life so
again it's not voluntary in this case
not free will
it's not free willing that when they put
a gun to your head or
not someone but life itself you know
hunger
puts a gun to your head so that's not uh
you know
very much uh free will okay
free you're not entering into a contract
there
on your on your own volition your own
you know
decision essentially someone decides for
you and that's your stomach
okay uh we have incipient industry we
have the guilds the craftsman the
merchants okay
all these people start developing i am
you know maybe around
1200 onwards even before that
you know i'm not going to go into the
details on that uh but essentially there
is a transition
okay what's the next uh transition well
we move into
manufacturing industry we heard you
heard of the industrial revolution
and that was around maybe the late 1800s
uh
i'm sorry uh late 18th century 1700s and
so on that's
when it's uh with some of the countries
like england and
france and germany they started coming
up you know they started creating
uh all these machines that they invented
the machines replaced
people in the farms people from the
farms had nowhere to go because there
was no
they were no longer necessary in such
numbers so they came to the cities
to work in the factories and the
factories produce machinery for the
farms and so that whole cycle
uh pushed people from the country to the
cities
and that's uh known as a transition
that transition is still ongoing today
okay
most countries that has pretty much
ended at least in the advanced nations
but in the
underdeveloped nations or the aspiring
nations
that process still going on okay
uh yeah farming begins the process of
uh in farming you know you have the
process of automation
and we have transition from the country
to the city
and the proliterium what does he do well
he has to exchange labor
for food essentially again uh not very
free
because the stomach uh compels you to do
something
you can't just go in there and say well
i'm not gonna work because then you
starve
okay because society is built around
work and it is a contract between
the uh owner okay
of uh machinery and factories and so on
we'll call them the industrialist
see uh it's a contract between the
industrialist and the worker but the
worker doesn't have much of a choice but
to
sell his labor that's all he has he
starts
being deprived essentially of being the
owner of goods he's no longer a
carpenter he's no longer a blacksmith
you know he he doesn't have a trade he
doesn't belong to a guild
in that sense in other words he's just a
worker who sells his labor for
an income and that income primarily
because he's at subsistence level more
or less
uh serves primarily uh to keep him alive
till the end of the month or uh
two weeks until he gets his next salary
okay um what's the next uh
step okay we go here and
that's uh we move especially in the 20th
century we started moving
into services services start taking over
muscling aside manufacturing that
transition takes a
place around in countries like sweden
one of the countries i know it took
place uh the united states
also around 1979 1980 thereabouts that's
when services
became a bigger percentage of labor
and of gdp and started muscling
manufacturing aside
remember after world war ii and in fact
shortly before that manufacturing
just exploded in the world they started
uh
inventing machines you know we forget
that
washing machines did not exist in the
19th century they they really started
in the 1940s 1950s that's when a lot of
these inventions really became popular
uh the phone the car all that started to
expand
and so manufacturing was expanding like
crazy
and there was a lot of work in
manufacturing well that
started changing after the 60s and by
the time you get to the
late 70s well it's taken over by
services
people a lot of automation was turned in
was introduced in the factories
and um there was a lot of innovation in
how things were done
and so you know uh manufacturing didn't
need as many people so
these people went into services the a
lot of people opened their own shops
became middlemen and they hired people
and so a lot of people went
uh from being a factory worker to being
maybe a cashier at a company
you know at a food outlet or whatever
okay so what happened uh yeah we have uh
the service worker but remember the
service worker is
at this point still okay it's labor
intensive it's
work that requires hands uh you can do
deliveries you can do cashier you can do
barbering there there's a lot of work
it's
it's uh service that you're doing but
you're it requires people it still
requires people
okay and again you see the percentages
there farming one percent
today more or less in advanced nations
maybe
between one and two percent uh
manufacturing anywhere between 15 and 20
for a lot of the advanced nations
okay and the rest is all services okay
so we're all doing services
some people always say uh so what okay
i'll try to address that i don't have
today but uh
i usually do okay and this is today uh
we should maybe put that now put it over
here
okay this is today different type of
service
okay it's internet worker it's uh
not the same types of uh service where
uh where um
you know you you actually have to have
hands-on when you use your hands
this is more abstract it's an
information
world information meaning that uh what
do we do well
what we do primarily is go on the
internet we create a site or whatever
and
it's uh usually some website creation
for what purpose for ads commercials
that sort of thing what to sell things
and that's keeping people working and so
people are getting out of
uh things where where you need hands
services where you need hands where it's
labor intensive
and we're more into this information to
leisure world
maybe for vacations for for things of
that nature
and even that's dying at least today
with this copic thing
okay so uh what happens now we're doing
action at a distance worker
okay we have this action out of this and
he doesn't have to go to the factory
or to the office you know you can do it
from home i think
there's gonna be a lot more of that you
know
people doing websites or working on the
internet lots of internet work
there's still demand for that and if
anything that's rising
and what's falling behind is you know a
person going to the mall
you know mall what is that what is a
mall i mean the malls are going to die
if we continue like this
and so are restaurants and hotels
and people will just do all their stuff
from home okay
so we're moving into a world in which
it's an information society
information economy and that's a little
different than the
services we had until now okay uh so we
have the rise of the internet
entrepreneur
okay the guy puts a little channel
and uh you know does something he gets
money for it versus
for somehow what for for creating
commercials
ads it's all about ads so we're all into
the ad
business so so to speak and we're also
in the leisure business we try to
entertain and so on okay so
that's where we're going headed okay uh
some play the stock market
play bitcoin okay bitcoin investor uh we
have the scam artists you know
the nigerian scams uh uh the girls you
know they go online they show whatever
they have
okay that sort of thing uh it's
entertainment it's um
leisure uh is that real work is that
uh long lasting work i don't know
uh you tell me okay so what's the deal
um here it is
uh these are my corollaries okay
this is what i get out of this this is
my take on this by the way okay
yesterday the clans were uh the haves
today it's the corporations which are
the haves
what do i mean by that they have the
goods
the solid goods the material goods
and they also have the food because we
don't produce food in our apartment then
you know on our carpet we don't grow
potatoes all that's done out there by
farms by specialists people who work
with machinery and they work all these
um
what would be called economies of scale
you know you have all these uh
farmlands being farmed by airplanes and
by
big combines and so on so they have
these big operations they produce food
for everybody
so they are the controllers of food and
they are the controllers also
of uh manufactured goods okay we don't
manufacture goods at home
uh certainly a lot of people would not
even be interested in doing that
they'd rather play piano you know with
the uh
little keyboard and let somebody else do
that whoever does that we don't know who
does it it just
somehow magically brings the product to
market
so the owners are someone else okay
someone else has become the owner
and in this case the owners of all
tangible goods
okay are uh corporations primarily
okay they're they're becoming if they're
not totally today they are certainly
becoming okay
that's one of the issues here they're
pushing everybody out even out of
services
uh manual services labor intensive
services
into uh the information world
okay okay he who is labor only has labor
to trade
trade is involuntary if it must be
traded for food
trade is involuntary if it must be
traded for food
subsistent wages is involuntary trade
leads to that that's what it equals most
labor today
is involuntary trade involuntary trade
is the fastest growing
segment of the global economy and
uh again we have this transition from
the country to the city that's
we're in the last phase of that if you
look at just
pick the country you want and just look
at its history in the last
40 years they've switched from uh
manufacturing and now they're into
service mode
just about every country in the world
most of its uh
uh gross domestic product and probably
its labor as well
is now due to services okay so the
percentages of services are arising
what's being crushed out or
being uh crowded out is uh manufacturing
and agriculture was crowded out a long
time ago
nobody does agriculture anymore you know
i mean well they still do
but but i mean that's dying as well big
corporations are taking over the small
farms
okay and then urbanites uh people in the
cities they rely more and more on
subsistence
wages okay you have devaluation you have
real value and again
which is you know being lost because
again when you devalue the coin or
or throw more money into the into the
pool suddenly they've reduced your wages
okay because that's what it means okay
more money in circulation means you you
suddenly
your your money is worth less not
worthless but worth
less right okay uh
so what's the goal the goal here is to
tell me
what's the next that's the object of the
game okay
what's the next service that you can
imagine we're not going back to
manufacturing
so inventions are done whatever you
invent is worthless
doesn't matter okay all you can do is
maybe make a minor change
in something cosmetic change and uh
so you know manufacturing really is not
going to pick up again
no matter what you invent i don't care
if you invent the machine that takes us
through the fourth dimension
it's not going to put billions of people
to work anymore not in manufacturing
blue-collar workers okay and agriculture
is already on its way out it's gone
almost out completely in many in
advanced nations very small percentages
again
and so uh we have services today and and
the services
are being crushed out in the direction
okay of information and the question is
okay uh that's gonna have its uh
exponential curve
now maybe the last bit maybe
a few months a few years i don't know
and then it's gonna reach an asymptote
when
you know that is saturated and the
question is
what can you imagine talking about
imagining now you know
smoke a pipe whatever you need take a
beer and just try to imagine you know
close your eyes try to imagine
what type of service we can invent next
what other sub-category of services you
can
you can imagine next okay
that will put people to work i mean
that's the point of this the point is
you know
we want to know where all the gdp and
all the labor is going to be
i don't know 50 years from now 100 years
from now okay
so try to imagine what the next services
are
and that's the goal okay again this is
uh part of the extinction theory or the
art
extinction argument and anyone who wants
to address that has to
go through extinction 101 before he goes
to extinction 102
for me to answer i mean if if they don't
cover extinction 101 i'm not even going
to bother why because
everybody's an expert in extinction 102.
in fact everybody's an expert in human
extinction
actually in how humans will not become
extinct they always tell me no bill
you're wrong
that's not how humans will become
extinct because of this listen
everybody knows how humans how humans
will not
become extinct what i'd like to see is
someone who knows
how humans will become extinct
that would be great you know we we need
a foolproof
mechanism for how humans will become
extinct
if you don't have one it means your
argument will be that humans will live
forever
and you might say well there's gonna be
a catastrophe well yeah maybe there will
be and maybe there won't
that's not foolproof okay
full and full proof both okay that's not
a foolproof
uh mechanism i need a foolproof
mechanism
of extinction something that will
definitely
necessarily kill man and i'm not talking
about the
sun being blown up five billion years
from now i'm talking about
maybe the next hundred five hundred or a
thousand years
if if that's what you think man is gonna
last
okay i'm saying he's gonna die because
of this because of the economics
you think it's not the case fine then
what you gotta do is come up with a
foolproof
mechanism that will kill man something
man
can't do anything about something man
can't do anything at all about you say
well man can do anything about anything
uh not so i can tell you one thing for
sure
okay hand in the fire for this one
man cannot have children okay humans
cannot have children
okay not anymore okay so the population
uh from now on will go uh in other words
the growth
population growth will it will be
asymptotic until it reaches a plateau
and then it'll start coming down
and the reason we can't have children is
because of several reasons
economics won't allow it culture has
changed
city folk can't have 10 children in an
apartment
et cetera et cetera et cetera there are
many reasons why we will not have
children women don't want to have
children
men don't either many of them so
now it's going to be sex for pleasure
recreational not reproductive
okay we will not have children the uh
last time we had
a high level of children was 1963
that's when we had like 2.1 growth world
this
global uh growth of population
and now we're down to one and if
everything goes
according to plans by mid-century if we
reach that far
it's going to get down to zero
population growth there one person is
born one person dies
there will be no growth in population
okay
and so we cannot have kids essentially
okay women will not have kids money
doesn't allow it
apartment doesn't allow it culture
doesn't allow it anymore
okay that's gone no woman's gonna have
10 kids okay
one maybe somewhere that's gone
all our grand great grandmothers used to
have five ten kids no problem
half of them died no problem either
today we don't have kids
so yeah there are things man can't do
anything about and one of them is having
kids okay
kids are out no that'll never happen
again
okay so um that's that's the deal
okay uh you gotta figure out what the
next uh
type of service will be and here um
i have something here see if i can find
it
yeah here it is
uh here's the chart that uh summarizes
more or less my argument okay i'm saying
that
uh for over 200 000 years we were hunter
gatherers
okay and about
uh ten thousand years ago these numbers
are by the way very um
uh you know very general you don't have
to
put your hand in the fire for the
numbers okay but these are just numbers
to make my case
uh you can add or subtract thousands of
years from them
okay so you have hunter gathering over
200 000 years then you have
farming agriculture
for about 10 000 years in general
maybe two to 300 years we did industry
okay and you can see that agriculture
started
dropping as manufacturing increased
there the the green versus the blue
okay where it says 200 years okay so
manufacturing starts rising
agriculture starts dying and i didn't
um i didn't take it all the way down but
you can see the trend
agriculture is going down all the way to
our days
today it's a very small percentage and
again
that percentage is still high because
there are other countries that are still
doing agriculture that's why that
that stack is that bar is still uh
big okay but essentially what uh
we see is that uh both agriculture
manufacturing have been pushed aside
by services and
this was an old graph where i put
unemployment and essentially
what i mean by that is that services is
simply a different
way of saying unemployment anyone who
does services
especially if they do internet stuff
well i don't think they have a job
okay that's my take on it that's not a
real job again you're
trading labor for uh salary
for wages uh you're not the owner
of tangible products and so i consider
that
like you're one of the have-nots
but even if we don't look at it that way
if you look at services we what we see
in the last few years is that
we've changed the labor service the
labor intensive services
for what we could call self-service or
you know everybody's an entrepreneur on
the internet
well in that sense you are a self
a an entrepreneur a guy who does it by
himself
maybe you do some investment in the
market in the uh
or in bitcoin or whatever so it's no
longer
you going to the rock pile to the mine
and working there or in a farm or
something like that
it's a different type of service okay
okay
so uh the
object of the game is to come up with
ideas that's the id that's the object of
the game
uh tell me what services we're gonna
move on to next if you cannot imagine it
for sure you're not gonna become a
millionaire okay
you gotta imagine to become a
millionaire okay so
in a way uh this hopefully it stimulates
your imagination and you become a
millionaire
okay so uh let's move on to the subject
matter of today which is
schrodinger's cat and uh
just to do a little uh review there
recap um i started a couple weeks ago
talking about the origin of the universe
actually the origin of matter i'd rather
call it origin of matter it's
more precise and according to
mathematical physics it started with a
big bang
okay so we start with a big bang and
then we look at the evolution
of this matter because as soon as the
big bang happened you didn't have
stars and galaxies and atoms no no
according to mathematical physics that
took a
process we started with sub atomic
particles such as quarks and so on
that built atoms from there we built uh
gases the gases
uh clustered around built these galaxies
and within the galaxy from those same
gases
the stars came out that's the general
picture that i covered
well from there i moved on to uh
particles especially quasi-particles and
pseudo particles which is simply
outrageous
i like them i like to call them quasis
because
you got to be crazy to
propose particles that are not particles
okay but these are a little more
far-fetched than the
uh typical particle that we had with
quantum the
i guess you could call it classical
quantum mechanics
where you have the particle and then
from there we moved on to the pseudo
particle the quasi particle okay
okay and then we looked at some of the
properties of these
particles and those are scary uh
we covered the other day spin which
ain't spin in other words uh they use
that word spin and it's very misleading
because we're not talking about spinning
like a top
we're talking about a different kind of
spin which they haven't even been able
to define they don't even know what it
is
okay but whenever they want to give a
physical interpretation they use the top
analogy they're talking about that
spinning like a top
uh that's not what spin is not in
quantum mechanics
and from there well we're moving on
today to another property and
just like spin canada is related to this
uncertainty principle that
werner heisenberg came up with uh in the
late 1920s okay so what is this
cat uh
quite a tale pun intended the cattail
schrodinger's cattail
his uh cat in a box
okay so this is summary so let's start
with a summary and then do with uh
with explaining it okay or describing it
schrodinger's cat is an analogy for a
particle so you have to think of a
cat as an analogy
and this is for a particle why did he
choose a cat well because of what he's
going to talk about but
the point is that he's talking about a
macro object a world
an object of our macro world and the cat
obviously is from our macro world
and he's going to turn that more or less
it's it's properties of this cat
he's going to try to explain the
properties of a particle
with this cat so he assumed that
whenever he says cat he's talking about
a particle
okay uh one of the problems is that so
the cat represents a particle okay
the so-called particle is merely a
probability function
okay so this so-called particle is not a
particle
not what you think a particle is it's
not a corpuscle
or what they call a classical particle
it's not
something it's not something period
it's not something it's nothing that's
what it's an equation
they call that equation a particle as
long as you keep that
in in the back of your mind you don't
lose track of that you'll be okay
you know i won't hurt you okay the
particle is described
by a wave function the wave function
what proposes that a quantum mechanical
particle is spread out
and occupies all of space something a
cat can't do
you know this is a smeared out cat in
three dimensions
so this poor cat uh you know occupies
all of space
right and they call them a particle
when does the cat become a car particle
when when he condenses into a cat-back
again
so he has these magical powers that the
cat can be
a little cat like your your cat at home
if you have one
right and as long as you don't look at
it
or touch it or whatever it suddenly
occupies all of space it's only when you
turn around and
suddenly you look at the cat then then
the cat turns back into a cat so you
never catch him in that
moment when he occupies all the space
okay but that is the theory essentially
okay this distinguishes the fact that
they have this uh
spread out thing it distinguishes that
from a classical corpuscle
okay which is again the typical particle
everybody thinks about a little ball a
little b
little grain of sand that's what we're
talking about when we say classical
shirting here put what happens to a
micro
subatomic particle in macro world terms
in other words you have to remember that
for all practical purposes what we would
say today
schrodinger was a dissident he was a
dissident from what he
he he disagreed specifically with niels
bohr and werner heisenberg
which came up with this copenhagen
interpretation of quantum mechanics
and schrodinger like einstein they were
not too fond of that
and so he was trying to make sense of
that somehow and he said well you know i
don't know
is that how the subatomic world really
behaves like all these people are saying
and so he he was a little bit skeptical
so he created this analogy this
tale the cat tale to
to try to put it in layman's terms so
that people would understand
what the mathematicians were doing what
they were saying what they were
proposing for them
for the microscopic world okay so that
was his intention so
schrodinger wants you to understand how
absurd how
ridiculous the physical interpretations
of quantum mechanics
are okay he wanted you to understand
exactly what he's talking about there
okay
and this is uh important because uh
you have to remember schrodinger he won
a nobel prize later on
because of his equation which was an
important equation by the way
uh it essentially mapped uh what an atom
looked like
okay which was good what what an element
a
a standard element of the uh
periodic table what it looked like you
could map
it with with his equation that's that's
very
fancy stuff it's it's really good stuff
but by the 1930s especially by the time
he writes 1935
when he comes up with his cat
tail cat in a box tail um
uh you have to remember there's a
there's this uh
struggle for quantum mechanics there's
the uh the
copenhagen people like uh niels bohr and
uh
werner heisenberg and they were saying
this is
how quantum mechanics actually behaves
that's what we observe in the lab
and this is our conclusion and you have
on the other side people like einstein
and schroedinger
they said they were a little skeptical
that that's how the
microscopic world works they had no
other explanation
of their proposal but they said look
there's there's a lot we still don't
understand
it can't be that that's how mother
nature runs her shop
in that secret world of hers and so uh
einstein wrote
in the same year that schroedinger
writes his cat uh tale
einstein writes his um epr paper where
he questions whether
quantum mechanics is a complete theory
and immediately he got a response from
niels bohr
a few months later in 1936 he got a
response from
niels bohr saying yeah yeah it's we're
done that's it
it doesn't get any better than this and
schrodinger abandoned
physics and started talking about
writing books about you know philosophy
about
how uh the mind interfaces with quantum
and that sort of thing he got lost in
some other stuff
he he essentially you know got out of uh
physics like saying there's nothing more
to investigate there i'm done with
physics
okay okay so that's uh that's the
backdrop or a background to uh
what was going on in those days and
here's uh the exact um
story it's told by mr um schrodinger
himself
he says again he wrote this in 1935 and
he says
it is also possible to construct very
ridiculous
cases imagine what he's saying there
okay imagine a cat
locked up in a room of steel together
with a following
heelish device which has to be secured
from direct
attack by the cat a tiny amount of
radioactive material is placed inside a
geiger count
inside a geiger counter so tiny that
during one hour perhaps
one of its atoms decays okay
uh but also with equal probability
perhaps
none do in other words he's talking
about uh radiation you know
some uh radioactive element okay
and so he says if it does decay then the
counter is triggered and through a relay
act through a relay activates a little
hammer which breaks
a flask a glass flash right containing
hydrocyanic acid you know some poisonous
gas
after this system has been left alone
for one hour one can say that the cat is
still alive provided no atom has decayed
in the meantime
the first uh the the
the first decay of an atom would have
poisoned the cat
in terms of the uh function
of the entire system this is expressed
as a mixture of a living
and a dead cat okay so they're talking
about probabilities here okay
it is typical of these cases that in
indeterminacy or
again remember that's the word that
heisenberg used for his uncertainty
principle as well indeterminacy okay
that an indeterminacy originally
restricted to the atomic domain becomes
transformed into
macroscopic indeterminacy
okay so that it affects the the real
world
our world macro world okay which can
then
be resolved by direct observation
in other words he says that what you got
to do is to verify that that's really
hap
what happened that the atom decayed is
by
peeking inside the box somehow okay
that's what he's saying
uh so here's the um
uh translation of that okay this is what
he's
saying in few words a cat is placed in a
box containing radioactive material
in a vessel okay there's an equal
probability that in one hour
one atom will decay or won't in other
words a radioactive
atom right shoots some particle out of
the out of the atom okay
spontaneously the geiger counter is
connected to a hammer that breaks the
glass flask
containing poisonous gas if decay has
taken place
but we don't know if decay has taken
place so the only way to verify
whether decay has occurred is by opening
the box
and checking whether the cat died or not
then you know that
an atom has decayed okay that was
the gist of it okay uh so
so you get the picture the picture is we
put a cat in a box
and the cat the only way to verify if
there's a decay
uh if uh radioactivity has taken place
in there
is by opening the box and verifying
whether the cat is dead or alive
until then he's in this uh probability
world
world of probability which is what
quantum is all about it's about
probability
it's just equations and what they're
saying is what is the likely probability
of for example an electron being here
not there that's one of the
probabilities they look at that's uh
part of the schrodinger equation it's a
uh
what they call a wave function
essentially it's a
spread out thing covers everything all
the way to the edge of space-time
and the particle can be
almost anywhere except you know for some
reason i never
could get an answer to that it cannot be
beyond the
the surface of an atom it's got to be
within that it's got to be within what
is known as a
a an orbital or a an energy
uh level okay those are the terms they
use
you would think that that particle could
go all the way to the edge of the
universe now it's the
wave that goes here okay i guess this
wave is spread out anywhere it wants to
because the wave has no
limit no boundary but whenever you
look at it you you try to detect it
measure it or whatever
it collapses to a point that's that's
the argument
and that's that's the theory and this is
along those
same lines um you know the cat
the only way you you're gonna know if
there's been a decay
you gotta look at the cat okay is it
alive or dead and until then
he's in this um world of probability
that he could be
half dead or half alive as they say or
he hasn't chosen whether he's going to
collapse to a particle or not
in other words he's in limbo he's out
there like you don't know really
it says more about what your knowledge
is of what's going on inside the box
okay so again people have a little bit
of problems trying to understand it
in macro terms because you say well hold
it until i peek
isn't the cat either alive or dead in
there
he's got to be one or the other whether
i peak or not
peaking only certifies you know whether
the cat is dead or alive that's all it
does but he he had to be
dead or alive even before that and that
happened when the
decay occurred okay the fact that you
have no
knowledge of what's going on inside the
box that's a separate issue
but you know the mathematicians haven't
figured that out
okay um so here is um
here's the notion i guess this is a way
of
putting it this has to do with
superposition uh meaning that particles
can be simultaneously one on top of the
others as well as
spread out okay and it says that the
superposition
means or it implies that the cat is in
all possible states okay so i don't know
if there's
any other state for a cat to be in uh
other than alive or dead maybe he's
scratching maybe he's not i don't know
but
for sure uh they're they're talking
about whether he's alive or dead so it's
a black or white it's a
coin toss you know it's heads or tails
okay that's it
in other words the cat is both dead and
alive before we open the box and peek
inside
in mathematical physical terms right
math is that's what this is all about
right
that cat is a tiny ball and a smeared
out wave
both because the probability of the cat
being both
is simultaneous in other words he's both
a particle and he's a wave
okay that's that's complementarity for
you
the complementary principle and then
conclusions of the mathematical physics
is
is that subatomic particles behave in
strange ways
that we don't observe in our macro world
well yeah that's one way of looking at
it and i'll show you a different way of
looking at that
uh give me a second here let me pull
this up
okay uh well i just want to point out
that this
has to do also with heisenberg's
uncertainty principle okay and we talked
about that the other day
just briefly heisenberg says that when
the ball is standing still it doesn't
move and when it moves it doesn't stand
still
he made an equation there and because of
that he got a noble prize
okay great for math terrible for physics
because yeah we all know that when you
stand still you don't move and when you
move you don't stand still
and the more you stand still the less
you move the more you move the less you
stand still
great i mean he really deserves a noble
for that
okay uh here's the
here's the many worlds version that we
have today for
which is probably the most popular
version of
the cat uh in the box tale okay
which is uh that there are many worlds
out there
for every step you take you branch off
into a different
universe there are gazillions gazillions
i mean
literally gazillions over gazillions
over gazillions of universes out there
and every time you take a step you
branch off into one of these universes
okay and you see the illustration at the
bottom
anything that can happen does indeed
happen
okay so it's not that it can happen
that's not just that it can
it will happen it does indeed happen
so when you took that step today you won
the lottery you died you were alive
you wrote a car you did all these things
simultaneously but
every time in a different universe
so you have all these histories out
there okay so in this universe the cat
is alive and another one
it is dead okay and when you open the
box the world histories
uh uh split in other words what you have
is
the splitting of all these universes all
these world histories
for every action on earth
for every person on earth this is what
these people are proposing
forget about the spirits of traditional
religions that was easy to understand we
can even understand god making the
universe he just takes his magic wand
goes abracadabra creates it we can all
imagine and
understand that this you cannot
understand
what do you mean for every step i take i
branch off into a different universe
in this one i was shot you know by a
gunman i died and the other one i won
the lottery and the other one i drove a
car and
what is this this is more than so
realistic it's just
idiocy to the what to the gazillions
power
according to how many universes are out
there what is it is this science
is this really science is this what
mathematical physics has come down to
and so yeah the universe splits and
creates copies where all possible
outcomes
are come true they are true and yeah
uh it's up to you to wonder whether this
has anything to do with physics anymore
all i can give you is my conclusions and
here they are
okay this one this is my take on this
i'm saying that schrodinger came up with
thought experiment as a way to argue
that this theory did not make any sense
he was essentially laughing at the
interpretations of quantum mechanics he
says look
you can't really put this in macro terms
which by the way bora and uh
heisenberg agreed to he says language is
not sufficient to describe this that's
the way they put it it says
we can only describe it mathematically
but then if they can only describe it
mathematically they're only going to
provide an idiotic
explanation why do they even attempt
to give a physical interpretation to
what they
to their equations they should leave it
at math
and math only a description a
mathematical description then we're done
we're okay with that no problem
they want to describe what they observed
and they want to describe it in terms of
point particles that's fine but
leave it at math don't tell me that
you've proven the existence of particles
especially particles which aren't
particles even less if they're pseudo
particles or
quasi particles no you got to leave it
man you want to talk math
talk math talk equations don't tell me
that you know something about the real
universe about the
microscopic sub micro new sub
microscopic
sub atomic universe because your
equation says something
now that's your physical interpretation
and if it's idiotic
well we have to apply uh karl popper we
have to say that look uh
falsifiability i mean if you believe in
karl popper's falsifiability saying that
any experiment
debunks your theory if we can show an
experiment that
shows that your theory cannot even in
this case not even be imagined
then of course you have to apply karl
popper in that situation
not that i do i don't care about carl
popper but the mathematicians you know
they they love uh karl popper um
and uh they love falsifiability they say
experiment the
debunks theories well here their theory
is that the particle can be at two
places at once
or that it suddenly converts into a
particle no one can even imagine that no
one can imagine many worlds
and here these uh here this is when they
are supposed to be applying karl popper
uh paparian falsifiability this is the
moment
and they haven't done that okay instead
uh you know
[Music]
instead of uh accepting the ridiculous
uh
explanation rather than they accept them
instead of
rejecting the particle hypothesis i mean
they should erase the board and say well
no we can't do this with particles
the problem is particles if you're going
to try to explain
you know being at two places at once
with particles you're gonna have a tough
time and of course you're gonna invent
principles
uh like you know the uncertainty
principles
or or uh superposition principles saying
oh a particle can be
two places at once or or two in one
place
you're gonna invent all that because you
have no way of explaining with particles
especially anything related to
action at a distance okay you can't
explain tunneling you cannot explain
entanglement you cannot explain any of
those action at a distance
phenomena including for that matter uh
gravity and
magnetism which you know you can
do it with what a couple magnets as i
always do you know you got
two little magnets there and there you
have it okay so how do you explain this
you know you're gonna use superposition
you're gonna use
what in between the two magnets okay and
gravity is the same thing
so yeah they cannot explain all this and
you cannot explain it with discrete
particles
what they should have done is abandon
the particle and apply
paparian falsifiability which is what
they love okay they love preparing
possibility
uh falsifiability we can call it the
falsifiability
principle the puckerium principle this
is where they should apply it we should
reject
particles and if not then again they
should not
uh try to translate their equations into
physics
okay because all they have is irrational
explanations
anyways uh so my conclusion is that
what they have today is no different
than religion and traditional religions
in fact i'd go further and say that
religion
traditional religions are more rational
than what these people do
because we can imagine everything from
traditional religions
everything we can imagine the mechanisms
are irrational are supernatural and the
proposals are supernatural
you know angels spirits god uh the devil
heaven all that stuff is supernatural
you know so we start off on the wrong
foot
but we can imagine the mechanism we can
imagine well to some degree we can
imagine
at least god waving his magic wand and
saying abracadabra and creating the
universe
okay we don't know what the process is
uh from one frame to the other where
something appears
after nothing was there yeah we we
cannot imagine that but we can
we can also we can picture what the
person is talking about
we cannot imagine one particle being at
two places at once
and so again uh this
is not only uh
like traditional religions it's much
worse
it's much worse than traditional
religions because it's totally
irrational you cannot even
imagine it okay
with that i'm gonna go into questions
here we had quite a few of those
okay and so here we go with the first
one
fellow says explain how these invisible
intangible object double ropes
okay we're talking about the rope
hypothesis which is what this channel is
about okay we say that
light is a rope okay torsion along a
rope
okay there's a physical mechanism that
underlies light in other words right
and a physical entity that underlies
light
okay so he says how these ropes uh
single thread produce
uh chladni uh patterns uh sacred
geometry and
semantics especially when you say there
is no frequency
i don't know what he's talking about as
far as frequencies is because
there is frequency frequency is a
trade-off between
uh link length and the number of links
frequency is number of links so we say
that
frequency is there it's just that we
don't call it frequency we call it link
lengths or
number of links okay and sacred geometry
that sounds like
religion also so anyone who talks about
sacred geometry must be talking about
some
virgin or god or some nonsense like that
you know i don't know what do you mean
sacred geometry geometry is you know uh
like euclid's geometry one one type of
geometry uh plane
planes and solids that's geometry
nothing sacred about that
so i don't know what this nonsense of
sacred is maybe some peop
these are religious folk you know people
who are religious
fanatic uh mystics
you know they invoke the spirits and
they talk about sacred geometry
just a laugh okay when the plate is
excited some areas vibrate and some
areas don't move that's what the
schlatni
patterns are okay more specifically you
are able to see the standing waves along
the nodal lines of the plate the sand
moves away from the antinodes etcetera
etcetera
as you can see he's not explaining
anything
and you can read all that later on
you'll find out there's no
explanation of the cause of the
mechanism
all this father is doing is describing
okay keep that in mind that's what it's
about here okay
if i was just describing because of
course he has no explanation but he's
asking me to explain it okay
okay so what do we have here um
here's uh let's follow schladny okay so
you know what he's talking about
and uh so he he gave by the way a uh
link so i went to that link and someone
wrote about this fellow
and his name is ernst sladney and he was
uh paul who did some experiments in the
late uh 18th century
beginning of the 19th century okay and
one of the uh the that site starts out
with a
quote from nicola tesla okay
and obviously good old nick he was not a
very smart guy as far as science was
concerned he was just an
inventor okay which has nothing to do
with science
and he says if you want to find the
secrets of the universe think in terms
of what
energy frequency and vibration well none
of those are physical
objects so pearl nick yeah he had no
clue
so i i want to make sure that we
put the correct statement there if you
want to understand a mechanism
think in terms of objects okay that's
the only way you're ever going to have
a mechanism okay and so we don't care
about the secrets of the universe or
about
sacred geometry whatever nonsense that
is no we care about
mechanisms okay that's what physics is
about
explain the mechanism can we see sound
uh the fella who wrote that piece right
the one that
the link was in uh said can we see sound
and he
clarifies not directly but we can come
close
okay so first of all we notice that uh
we will not be able to see sound the way
this fell uh
who wrote about sacred geometry believes
the guy on the left
okay he believes that we can see sound
this guy clarifies that up front says
can we see sound not directly okay but
we can come close so we don't know what
he's talking about are we going to look
at it with one eye are we going to look
at that without eyes and just do it by
braille or what what are we what is he
talking about
he says we now know oh we know
that sound propagates in ways
again you can see that's idiot talk
nobody says that
a flag propagates in waves that's not
the way
a rational human talks rational human
says
the flag waves see how simple it was
what do you mean
propagates in waves the note says saying
you can say
the flag waves not that it propagates in
waves
anyways through a solid gas or liquid
medium schlatney
paved the way for what for experimental
acoustics
experimental uh already shows me that
this guy is not going to be doing
science he's going to doing
something about experiments about
something he observed that he cannot
explain and it says he was able to
determine sound velocities in gases well
that's only a description i don't care
if he can determine
sound velocities because that's not an
explanation of anything
okay and what is he talking about he's
talking about this okay
this is what it is he's going to shake
this plate and you you know
some sand or whatever on top of it and
he create creates all these patterns
okay and these are the chladni patterns
okay
okay so you see them very nice very
beautiful a lot of people
watch some of these videos uh this one
had
16 million hits and the guy had never
explained anything
again just uh flashy stuff that he puts
on the screen which other people buy
uh probably the people who believe in
what uh
sacred geometry they they are hypnotized
by this stuff and that's
not a single one can explain it and so
we look for an explanation in this guy's
site and say
okay let's see what what what you can
explain
and he says how here's how it works i
said oh great someone's going to explain
how it works
it says when the plate is excited some
areas vibrate and some areas don't move
okay so far that's a description okay
then he continues says more specifically
you are able to see the standing waves
along the nodal lines of the plate
so far we have a description no
explanation for how it works
you know what makes these things do what
they do
the sand moves away from the antinodes
where the amplitude of the standing wave
is maximum
and toward the nodal lines where the
amplitude is minimum
forming patterns known as platini
figures again description description
description
all we have so far our description there
is no
explanation anywhere in in in that whole
thing
okay so
so far we have no explanation and uh and
you read the
the uh link there the rest of the link
of that
article and the guys ends with this
or more or less he continues with this
but this is his
essentially his punch line you know his
conclusion he says we've seen how the
patterns on a chladni
plate are created but what do they mean
what do you mean how they are created he
never explained anything oh we
we don't know how they are created
meaning explanation
all we know is that uh there's a
vibration and
for some reason uh they form these
patterns
these nodes antinodes all that stuff we
still don't have an explanation of the
mechanism
what's causing the grain to move from
here to there that's what we want to
understand
okay and we don't have an explanation
and uh
so he says all all objects including
plates have a set of natural frequencies
at which they vibrate
description that's not an explanation so
far okay
a system such as standing waves in a
musical instrument tends to vibrate at
certain
certain discrete frequencies called
natural frequencies or iron frequency
again all this is description we don't
have a single explanation
okay so the guy uh this fellow he um
he wants an explanation but like
suggesting we have an explanation you
don't
well yes i do have an explanation but
i'm not going to give
i'm not going to give it because you
know first i'd like to see an
explanation for those folks
who go out there and put all these
vibrations things on the internet all
over
both in blogs and in youtube
i want them to come up with an
explanation physical
explanation what is happening and for
this they're going to have to use
objects right they have to explain how
some object affects another object
we want to see a mechanism and until we
see a mechanism
there is nothing to address okay all we
have is a description something fancy
it's like saying look i can do a magic
trick too i have
two magnets and i put them together and
they stick
now isn't that magic and i can also pour
some
iron filings and i can create all these
fancy patterns
and they tend to stick towards the
center of the magnet
and if they're in the positive area they
get away from the negative area
you know all those are descriptions i
still don't have a mechanism
and so the guy wants an explanation but
he doesn't even know what an explanation
is
because he thinks he's got some kind of
explanation to begin with
okay so that's that's where the problem
is okay
people don't understand the difference
between a description and an explanation
okay uh next one
paul says uh here he is problem with the
definition
of object he still thinks that he
doesn't like my definition of the object
can you believe that
the red square is not an object he says
okay the
the green tree showed near the red
square is not an object
either okay the object is not an object
2d objects don't exist
well again it's one of the problems here
is first they never tell you what
the definition of the word object is
that's the first one and then the second
one is they take for granted that the
word exists means exactly exactly
exactly the same thing as the word
object
which is what we've had for the last 400
years 500 years
really everybody thinks that the word
object means the word exists and
everybody thinks that the word exists
is exactly a synonym of the word object
an object is that which you can touch
or see three-dimensional etc surface the
surface that's the way they see it
because if it doesn't exist it's not an
object
so obviously they say well does a square
exist
well you're talking about something else
you're not talking about the word object
we want to get to the word object before
we talk about existence
and these people jump the gun and they
say see it doesn't exist
we're not talking about existence we're
not talking about existence and as long
as you
introduce the word exist in there you're
going to run into trouble
okay and so yeah the word tree does the
word tree
refer to an object always
whether it's the imaginary one which is
the two dimensional one i drew there or
took a picture of
or the real tree i have outside in my
garden
does the word tree does the word answer
the question
don't don't change your your uh
you know don't go off on a tangent just
answer the question
does the word tree always hear on the
other side of the universe in the land
of the klingons does the word tree
always refer to an object
okay that's the question okay and
you gotta answer that question for that
you gotta define the word object
you gotta say what the word object is
and don't confuse it where the word
exists
that's how simple it is because if
you're gonna talk about existence talk
about existence don't talk about object
first you got to define the word object
then you can talk about the word
existence
because if you're going to talk about
whether an object exists
hopefully you're talking about something
different
in other words the word object is not a
synonym of the word existence first of
all
and second you got to define the word
object because you're going to talk
about
its existence or whether it exists or
not
means that there are objects you're
implying that there are
objects that don't exist and a square is
one of those
uh the square is an object because it
has shape that's the only condition to
be an
object physics doesn't deal with objects
that don't
exist physics deals with objects that do
exist but existence is something
different than object
object is different than the word exist
okay
okay uh and another fellow also followed
up on that so we may
never get through that uh a square isn't
an object
yeah if you've never defined the word
object you're never going to get past it
we're never going to know
or understand whether a square is an
object because
it's up to you to define the word object
and until you define it can defend your
definition
because everybody wants to copy a
definition they found somewhere and they
say oh i found this in the dictionary i
found it in
in some science book or whatever no no i
don't care where you found it i don't
care if it's your definition or someone
else's i don't care if every
person on earth votes for your
definition and that's what everybody out
there
likes to think of as far as an object is
concerned
we don't care about any of that you've
got to come here and defend
your definition if you're going to
criticize the definition you're going to
criticize no problem
begin by defining the word object then
you can criticize
it's very simple you know define the
word object
in a way that you can defend it meaning
that you can use it consistently
rationally and certainly anything
related to the word
touch the word uh c or
three-dimensional none of those will
pass the test
okay and if you talk about existence
again you gotta define first the word
object
we don't care about existence don't use
the word exist in any way shape or form
don't tell me whether
the fly is on one side of the square or
on the other that's existence
tell me whether the word square refers
to an object tell me whether the word
tree refers to an object
tell me if the word energy refers to an
object
and if not to what does it what what
category are you going to put it under
and what are these categories you have
to define these categories so that you
can put the word energy over here
the word spirit over there the word
angel over there god over here
uh tree over here rock there you gotta
be able to
to put these words under certain
categories
okay and i'm saying there's only two
categories that's it
all the words in the dictionary fall
either under object or concept
quickly just very briefly object that
which has shape
concept that which does not have shape
that's not the definition but that's a
good rule of thumb if it doesn't have
shape
the word refers to a concept and that's
why we have to define it
whereas objects we don't define we point
to them
okay because they have shape no problem
n-shape is the only universal property
that all objects have it's a universal
property of objects
so here's a rundown of that okay let me
put it over here
okay it goes something like this
don't tell me what it what an object
ain't tell me what it is
define the word object and don't tell me
what everybody believes out there don't
give me the
the definition of ordinary speech bring
in a scientific definition that you can
defend
that you can use consistently and
and again that does not involve the word
exist or or the notion of existence
in any way shape or form exist as a
separate matter you must define the word
object
in such a way you can use it
consistently which no one has ever done
especially in physics
okay don't bring authority don't bring
tradition don't be
bring democracy don't tell me that
everybody voted for it that's nonsense
we don't care about that
don't tell me that it's your opinion or
that everybody's opinion or the
mathematical establishments opinion we
don't care about that anyways
um it's my greatest contribution because
it destroys all religions
once you define the word object all
religions die okay
and that's how powerful that definition
is because it's
and all the people who complain are
religious folk they're defending some
spirituality something they have hidden
inside them
that's why they don't like the
definition because they realize
it destroys their religion that's the
only reason
that they oppose it and again all they
do is say what
an object ain't they never tell you what
it is
and when you realize that they only
criticize they say that that's not what
an object is
you know that they're religious people
they're fanatic uh spiritualists
otherwise they would define it it would
be very simple they would say no no bill
this is
this is the definition of word object
and so now we can get into a debate
because i can criticize his definition
he can say well
and he can defend it he can say no no
this is this is why
my definition is correct that's the way
it works in science now you have a
scientific debate
but to say i don't like your definition
everybody out there voted for my
definition
this is the one i found in the
dictionary uh
you're a religious fanatic now i know
here here we do science not religion
okay
don't do spirituality don't don't bring
uh
sacred geometry here okay we don't care
about sacred
nothing sacred here okay okay uh all
dictionary
words fall under two categories
religious folk philosophers metaphysic
uh
mathematical physicists and so on you
know they invent subcategories to get
around this okay
uh and what they do they introduce
adjectives
so they start qualifying the nouns they
say black cat
no longer a cat now it's a black cat and
likewise they say you know
why because they don't have a clear
clear-cut definition okay and so they
have to create all these sub-categories
to be able to fit their religion within
them so they say well uh they might say
that you know
square is an object but it's an object
that doesn't exist
yeah that's separate issue an inexistent
object yeah i don't care that get rid of
the adjective
just put the the word there tell me if a
square is an object don't tell me
whether it exists or not
don't tell me whether plasma is an
object because the word plasma means
ionized gas and that means that you've
got an
adjective ionized right in front of that
word i i don't need the word ionized
is plasma equal to gas yes or no if it's
not then don't tell me that plasma is a
physical object it's not
gas is an object ionized mean
plasma means that you did something to
the gas you ionized it
okay so yeah you got to be careful about
that
plasma is not a physical object not a
standalone object
you won't see it in a single frame you
can't make up you can't take a snapshot
of plasma because whatever you took a
picture of is standing still
and that's not plasma plasma is always
in motion plasma is always ionizing
otherwise it's not plasma
by definition pursuant to the definition
uh and so what these people do they want
to do physics by moving concepts around
okay and they
have these words like ether field wave
plasma vortex
energy electricity information they use
all these as physical objects
okay and that's why they end up with
irrational physical
interpretation because what they're
doing is moving concepts around
and they don't even realize that they
think that these words like field and
ether
are physical objects they're not right
they're always in motion there's no such
thing as a field standing still field is
a bunch of numbers from a given point of
view and numbers is counting
okay so you have motion everywhere there
one fellow says you're my favorite
atheist oh man
no no i've talked about this in the past
i'm not an atheist okay i used to be i
came from a militant atheist
family we were militant atheists we were
one of the
first members of american atheist when
it was founded by madeline murray o'hare
we used to live in baltimore near her
house and uh
my mother especially but both my parents
they became
members of uh they became friends with
madeline murray o'hare
for those of you who don't know her she
was the founder of american atheists
she was murdered uh later on in her life
okay
and uh a couple times she came to our
house
and so uh you know i started out being
in
an atheist home we used to talk about
religion
almost daily and i read the bible three
times before
by the age of 15 16 completely from
beginning to end a book that i love by
the way because not because of religious
stuff
but i don't care about any of that but
uh because it's a book that
tells you about how people thought
thousands of years ago
so it's a historical book it's a very
important book even though the
you know you'll see a lot of nonsense in
there even that nonsense is
important because it shows how people
were thinking in those days
two thousand three thousand four
thousand years ago what was important to
them
having kids uh you know spreading your
seed
uh building an empire you know all these
things that all these
farmers these uh shepherds were
talking about uh falling in love and
having women and so on
this is how they thought and so in that
sense at least the old testament is very
important
obviously the new testament as well but
it's more uh religious
more spiritual is i don't care too much
about the new testament i care more
about the old testament
anyways uh yeah i come from an atheist
background but
about 20 25 years ago you know i started
drifting away from atheism because i
realized that
um what is it uh atheism is the religion
of mathematical physics okay of the
mathematicians
why because it's uh it misconceived the
scientific method
they think they're doing science and
they're not they're into belief and
opinion
and that's the problem and so um
you know i i let's see if i have it here
uh no i don't um
i put it in a category uh of
what i call uh religion why because
anything related to opinion
uh has to do with religion and that's
what an atheist is an atheist is a
person who tells you he doesn't believe
or
he he knows for sure that god doesn't
exist
and that's not a scientific statement
okay the way we say in science is
let us assume god exists that's a
hypothesis
known as a hypothesis means you're going
to make an assumption
because god is not a theory you don't
believe in god you don't
disbelieve in god what you do is you
make an assumption about god his the
existence of god you say this
this object called god exists has
location
in the universe somewhere you know has
distance with respect to me
and he created the universe for example
you know theory
or he he created that flower he he
made the curtain move whatever i don't
care so
that's the way we treat it in science
science science you make an assumption
about the existence of something like
god
we don't say we believe in god we don't
say we don't disbelieve in god or maybe
god exists but i don't know
and maybe i'll prove it with an
experiment we don't do any of that
we make an assumption let me assume
allow me to assume i'm going to make an
assumption
that god exists that's how it works and
then you explain your theory
based on that assumption that's science
that's the scientific method not
what the mathematicians do saying oh
we've proven this
the particle can be at two places at
once we can't imagine it but we've
proven it here's the equation
that's not science that's religion the
worst kind of religion
okay another issue fella says
uh what if light is always directly
between atoms
then no matter how far away something is
we see it
where it really is only the brightness
and color
are delayed by speed of torque referring
to the rope
uh no uh i'm gonna take exception to
that
okay here's a a little picture
of what this gentleman is saying here it
is um
the question is whether a wave from the
andromeda galaxy
extends all the way to earth or whether
it sails like a sailboat you know like a
little sailboat
from uh andromeda over here is that is
extend
or travel that's the question in that
case the question is whether
you know this little sailboat has a
beginning and an end
is it just like that just little
sailboats coming to us
so where does that little wave begin
where does it end does it extend or
travel
that's the question and with the rope
model
you know you can explain that very
easily because the rope simply extends
you know from andromeda to us okay and i
think i
see it here let me wait for a second
here see if i can see the rope there i
think i
i put it in there maybe not
give me a second see if it comes out
after this
no i guess not uh i had another one
and unfortunately i didn't put that one
up there but essentially there's one
where
a rope is connected from the andromeda
from an atom in the andromeda galaxy all
the way to your eye
all the way to the earth and all we have
is a torsion
and of course that torsion is not
instantaneous
it doesn't that that thump that
gets to the atom in your eye is not
instantaneous once it's
once the uh the uh atom in the
andromeda galaxy does its quantum jump
it expands and contracts torques the
rope
that takes time to get here two and a
half million years
so so it's not instantaneous so no uh in
that sense
uh einstein was right you know we see
objects
when not where they were now but where
they were
if it's very far away like andromeda
galaxy we see them like they were
millions of years ago a couple million
years ago
okay so no it's not instantaneous the
torsion on our
on a rope is not instantaneous that's
what i mean
it takes turn time for that thing to
torque
all the way from andromeda all the way
to us it's fast 300 000 kilometers per
second
but it's not instantaneous it's not like
you know here's the blip and here we see
it no
it takes time it you know torsion is not
instantaneous
but it's for for our for practical
purposes you take a rope
you connect it between two poles and
like i said you put two
closed pins you move one the other one
moves instantaneously
in our macro world you would have to be
a great distance to notice that there is
that the torsion is not instantaneous
that the other one doesn't move
instantaneously it takes time for that
thing to get there
so no torsion is not instantaneous
just want to clarify my point of view on
that okay you people can believe
whatever they want but that's my take
okay here's another fellow he says uh
i'm really interested to understand how
do you understand the relationship
between mind thoughts and reality
and the process of obtaining knowledge
and proving some statement
as true etc etc he goes into
knowledge knowledge and knowledge okay
one of the problems here is the word
knowledge
what does this have to do with science
and again it's because we have the wrong
scientific method
and what i was talking about a minute
ago with this other fellow
who said whether i'm an atheist or
thought that i was an atheist no all
this
belongs in religion there you see the
word knowledge where do you see it under
religion
proof under religion okay experiments
uh sensations perception anything of
that is opinion
okay what do we use experiments for to
convince people to persuade
okay it's to believe to test their
belief to
to change their beliefs to change their
opinions that's why we do experiments
an experiment is not an explanation of
anything okay
science on the left hand side you know
it's a rational explanation
so no we do not do experiments in
science that's
in mathematical physics in religion
okay mathematical physics is an
irrational religion
why because they do experiments they do
equations so far we have
a description and observation and then
they say we've proven it
and here's the proof and what they're
trying to shove down your throat is
their physical interpretation
which they acknowledge is irrational
that you cannot even imagine it but
they've proven it
so what are we talking about we're
talking about you know uh
persuasion we're talking about proving
we're talking about
you know uh convincing recruiting we're
not talking about
objectivity we're not talking about
explaining something mechanically
so that you can understand it you just
want to understand it you don't want to
it's not about belief or opinion whether
you believe it or not
is your personal problem what you want
to do is understand it
that's science that's where science
stops understanding what continues is
belief
and that's religion same thing with
atheism you know uh
saying that you believe or don't believe
in god or whether you know that god
exists or not that's religion
that's religion because all you said is
your opinion we don't care
about your opinion we want you to
explain something and for that you can
say listen god exists and then you
explain it
with using god as the assumption that's
the way it works in science
that's why atheism is nonsense that's
why i had to abandon
atheism atheism is the religion of
mathematical physics
because mathematical physics clings to
an old-fashioned scientific method that
we inherited from the
people from the 17th century it's a 400
year old scientific method which
has nothing at all about scientific i
call it the religious method
yeah it's about belief okay another
falsehood i would love to hear you talk
about biology is biology science if so
is it physics or philosophy do viruses
exist
or are they concepts okay i think it's a
valid question to address
first i'll say that i'm not a doctor
so i'm no specialist in viruses all i
can do is give you my five cents worth
this is
back of the napkin type of uh
stuff that i'm gonna talk about here
okay here it is in a nutshell
yeah this is simply at the top of my kid
head
uh here's the description of a virus
it's a complex molecule consists of dna
rna
encapsulated within protein membrane
and much smaller than a bacteria okay
what does it do
uh well it's an inert parasite you could
call it okay
it's it's not alive it's dead okay it's
a molecule
okay that's all it is complex molecule
so it's uh but i call it an inert
parasite because it's like a stone that
you have in there but this is a special
type of stone
it tends to penetrate the cell walls of
the cells in your body
and it makes copies of itself uh of
itself using the cell material okay
that's my five cents worth on
on what a virus is is it a theory
is it a uh is it part of science is it
part of philosophy
well it's a theory okay in other words
the virus is the object
okay and they say it's a molecule this
molecule penetrates the cell and makes
copies of itself
well dna makes copies of itself and dna
is also
a molecule uh are we going to say that
dna is is
irrational well i think it's a dna is a
good explanation
it's a good explanation i like it i
partly because i understand it
i'm not an expert in this field but i do
like it because i understand it
someone shows me a picture of dna
trolling around saying
you know just twirling on its axis
and making copies of itself and i say
okay i understand what's happening there
so
to me it's rational because i can
understand it they can make a movie
and show you what's happening and with
the virus the same thing
it's this thingy inert thingy
it penetrates the walls of
a uh cell okay takes the cell material
which is also c-h-o-n chan
as i call it right and it makes copies
of itself
and by making copies of itself it
becomes
a parasite you know it's it should be
there it's a
it's something you have that's
artificial inside your body
making more and more copies of it so
yeah it's got to cause problems
in that region and then kill you you
know if it gets
too far so i understand the theory
and i understand what the people who
propose viruses
are telling me so as long as i
understand it i have no objection to it
and i don't have an alternative theory
because i don't care about that world at
all
you know i don't care about medicine or
any of that stuff so for me it's it's
good until someone comes with a you know
with a better mousetrap
and tells me look there's this other
theory here and again people should not
tell me what it ain't
don't tell me what that a virus ain't i
don't care about that all the arguments
against viruses i don't want to hear
that
i want to hear your what you propose in
instead
what is your theory for diseases or for
whatever
and in that sense yeah viruses as far as
i'm concerned
are part of science because it's
objective i can understand it they can
make a movie of their theory
and until again until i see another
theory that
uh that competes against it uh
it's not that i believe in it but what i
what i do is i use that same material
when i have to explain something i say
look this is a virus that enters the
cell and
makes copies of itself and a person said
do you believe in that well
i'm just going to use this as an
assumption for whatever i'm going to
talk about
that's it that's science science is not
about belief science is about
this theory makes uh is rational
makes sense to me and i'm going to use
it for something
and again tomorrow someone comes up with
a better theory well i might switch them
over i don't know
gotta wait for that day but yeah as far
as i'm concerned it's it's more or less
like
evolution is evolution a theory or is
evolution
uh proof has it been proven is it
is it a fact
no evolution is not a fact any more than
anything else
is a fact in science in science
in religion it's a fact in science
evolution is a theory it's known as a
theory what is a theory
it's an explanation the guy says look
we didn't we weren't born like this like
it says in the bible which is another
theory we were we we had this
process this lengthy process in which
uh something changed into something else
over time eventually came to be
what we are today and to me that the
whole cycle makes sense
to me i can visualize it i can picture
it
i can easily been like i showed in one
of my videos i could see the
intermediate missing links here and
there very
i mean we're talking about millions of
years so you can't get all the missing
links
but you can see some of the missing
links okay like you know how
uh life could have started you know i
put that in my book and uh
so again these are theories these are
explanations so that you
visualize them understand them and
that's where science stops
whether you believe that that's exactly
what happened well that's your personal
opinion it doesn't concern science at
all
science only stops at mechanisms and you
know show me the process how
how we came to be and i like the
evolution
theory no it's not a fact
it's a theory it's an explanation that's
all it is objective explanation
uh the explanation from traditional
religion
uh christianity god make the universe
well yeah
uh it's an explanation for me it's an
irrational explanation because first of
all i cannot conceive
of uh you know this this something from
nothing
okay turning something nothing something
from nothing you know retaining
empty space into a matter into an atom
i don't know what the process is there
if they can explain that process then
maybe i'll start
accepting it maybe i'll start using that
theory as well as
uh as an assumption until they can show
me that process i have nothing to borrow
from traditional religion
okay it's just nonsense okay because
they cannot explain a mechanism i need
the mechanism
i don't want you to tell me you believe
because the bible says that's authority
that's nonsense that's idiocy
okay and that's exactly the word that
you got to use idiocy
okay now the way it works in science you
got to say look this is the mechanism
this is the process
i can make a movie of it so that you can
understand it by just watching the
movie and that's what evolution is and
that's what viruses are
okay you can watch the movie and
understand it you understand it
we're done you believe in it we don't
care
okay another comment here moving on
uh why should all other mammals become
extinct with us
someone phil says okay uh all i'm gonna
say
is that you know when the dinosaurs died
as far as the record shows
like what they see in the rock they say
that
all animals and i don't know if all
animals but
what they see is that the only thing
that more or less survive their
animals the size of a cat or smaller
maybe the size of a chicken
okay that's it that's all that survived
anything that was big
was wiped out okay and i think the
reason for that is that
the big guys ate the little guys at the
last moment they whatever they
found so you got a t-rex who's
used to eating i don't know
triceratopses and suddenly they're not
around or he can't find
some and he's gonna go after the smaller
game he's gonna eat potato chips
and so he's gonna eat anything that he
can catch
and see if it's too little it's not
worth his
energy okay so
uh the way i look at it uh yeah when we
leave we're gonna wipe out every mammal
in town and we don't eat
usually we don't eat ants and we don't
need uh
you know other stuff like that uh even
though i think those are gonna disappear
as well a lot of those
but for sure any animal that is big in
the forest
wolves bears buffalo that's how we kind
of wiped out
we're gonna kill them the first day
uh those are to be wiped out within the
first few weeks and then after that you
know uh
there's nothing left for you to hunt out
there in the in the wild
because everybody's going to go out
there with their bow and arrow with
their guns whatever they have in
on their hands we're going to start
hunting whatever moving out there
and then they're gonna start hunting
hunters yeah that's the way it works
that's why you know i like to laugh at
these folks uh
i've got a saying here and it goes like
this
you know uh survivalist without a cause
is a hunter
and prepper without cause is a gardener
okay because you have all these
survivalists and preppers they're
preparing and you say what are you
preparing
for and they said well i don't know
maybe there could be a uh
flood or a forest fire or whatever is
that what they're preparing for
and we're preparing for the end of the
world whichever way it comes i don't
care
and maybe a lot of these people are
thinking nuclear weapons you know we
throw the
nukes at each other and so uh head for
the hills
and so here's the uh survivalist he's
going with his backpack his gun you know
he's gonna live out on the wild forever
you know
and it turns out the first thing that's
going to be wiped out is everything that
he wants to hunt
first thing that goes is wild animals
because uh everybody's going to go out
to the forest and
just catch whatever they can if they're
hungry everybody who lives near a forest
or even farther away they're just gonna
drive down there and say well i'm gonna
hunt something i'm gonna hunt the bear
if necessary
and cook them over a week you know so
they're gonna be killing animals and
besides that everybody's gonna be
killing each other
and i don't know how much you can live
off of
hunting animals especially when they
need to eat as well you know
when a lot of people go out there and
hunt animals they're just going to wipe
out the force in the jungles
that's why people say well how about
those lost tribes well there are no lost
rides we found them all
you know we've got satellites you know
we can see a match box
on the floor from the sky so there are
no lost
uh drives as some people believe still
out there
we found them all we know where they are
and in fact a lot of them
all of them all 100 of them are
protected
by governments here there was this
island in the middle of the indian ocean
there
between uh really between india and uh
the
indonesian peninsula there and uh
and the indian government has to protect
these people because otherwise people
would just go in there
missionaries especially with their
bibles and try to convert them and
it turns out the indians kill the
natives they killed
these uh missionaries and so the
government said don't go there we
want to keep them like they are you know
let them evolve or whatever you know
so so the government's protecting them
that they government is no more who's
going to protect those in those natives
they're just going to go in there and
kill them all
they're going to hunt people so this
notion that you know
uh when the world collapses we're all
going to be friendly and teaching each
other how to farm i really laugh at that
people really suckers or that kind of
thing they they think really they're
in a nashville jungle we're going to
have friends and families and
well families maybe but friends
neighbors they'll become enemies
overnight
okay so don't trust anyone no one trusts
anyone in the asphalt jungle
once the economy collapses nothing to
trade you gotta steal you gotta kill
no other way and that's what's gonna
happen uh nobody claims gravitational
waves are responsible
for gravitational attraction least of
all einstein we consider gravity a
geometric phenomenon
of curved space time claims made about
gravitational waves
involve the ability to move beads along
a rod
and note a resulting temperature
increase
okay let's find out well here
uh let's look up first the definition of
what a gravitational wave is
okay so here it is here's a
gravitational wave and this is out of
the wiki it says gravitational waves
transport energy whatever that is okay
uh as gravitational radiation whatever
that is
what is radiation what is energy a form
of radiant
energy huh similar to electromagnetic
radiation
whatever that is okay there you see a
picture on the bottom these are
gravitational waves
from some mass that moved so move
some object moved out there in space
they call
the object a mass they say that space is
made of this stuff called space-time or
some kind of
medium continuous medium and so whatever
moves or shakes
that uh that space-time thingy canvas
uh three-dimensional fishnet whatever
you want to call it
uh that wave moves everywhere
including to here on earth and so then
what is the purpose of a
gravitational wave if it doesn't do
anything related to gravity gravity
pulls
i mean the earth would fly out of the
solar system if it weren't that the
sun somehow keeps it there
okay and we say well it's gravity and in
the case of space-time
we talk about warp space we say that the
canvas is warped
and that's why the earth cannot go
outside that
that wall of time wall of time that
prevents the earth physically from going
out
whatever that means because that's
that's what these people are saying
they're saying there's a depression of
space
time time is warped it forms a circle
and the earth orbits around that circle
like the little ball around the roulette
okay
and what comes up against the skin of
the earth is work
time that is the explanation
so what what uh
role does a wave a gravitational wave
play in that scenario that's the
question
and so here we see a little something of
that
a little uh illustration of that and it
goes something like this you see
the two mechanisms for uh
why the earth according to to ration to
uh relativity why the earth would fly
out
instantaneously out of the solar system
uh not according to raw three according
to newton uh the earth would fly
out of the solar system instantaneously
according to the equation
newton's equation if the sun happened to
disappear there is no mass
you know you have mass mass divided by
distance square one of those masses is
now zero it's gone
so the question is according to newton
the earth which is the top
uh picture on the right would fly out of
the solar system
instantaneously as soon as the sun
evaporates so here you see it evaporate
here in a second
there it goes bloop and the earth flies
out
instantaneously why because uh the mass
is not there that's newton's
theory that's newton's equation what's
on the bottom well the relativity
version
what you see on the bottom is that the
sun is going to disappear here you'll
see it in a second
it evaporates but the earth continues
rolling around the sun
until the gravitational wave
reaches the earth and the gravitational
wave cannot travel
faster than light at most it travels
exactly at the speed of light
we got a problem with that because that
is irrational they're saying that the
mass
called the earth is revolving or
orbiting
the mass called the sun even though
there is no sun
anymore and they say well the the signal
cannot travel
faster than light from the sun to the
earth so the earth would not find out
gravitationally
that the sun has gone that's the that's
the argument
and so we have a problem there because
uh
the question is what is the role of that
gravity wave
i mean if there's no sun and here's the
gravitational wave still going
what does the gravitational wave do does
it while it's
while the sun is still there does it
pull on the earth what is the purpose of
a gravitational wave
why did they put the word gravitational
in front of the word wave
if that wave is not going to do gravity
and if it is going to do gravity then
yes i'm right the
the uh what these people are trying to
tell you is that the gravitational wave
pulls on the earth otherwise it has no
purpose what is the purpose of a
gravitational wave if it doesn't
uh do gravity why did they put the uh
that adjective in front of it calling it
gravitational
okay so that's the issue
and so yeah uh
you got to tell me what a gravitational
wave does
and this vowel says it just uh throws
energy
or radiation whatever so what's that
radiation for why do we call it
gravitational wave i mean that sounds
like
electromagnetic wave that also brings
radiation to your eye or
light or whatever you want to call it
energy so
in what way is a gravitational wave
different from
an electromagnetic wave if if uh
i i you know we would think that if they
put the word gravitational it has to do
something with pull
with a pull of gravity but if it's not
going to pull if it's just going to
reach the earth
and the earth is just like light and
just notify us that the sun is no more
then that sounds like light it doesn't
sound like gravity at all
so again what is the purpose of the
so-called gravitational wave
okay final question or a comment that a
person made
and he says um
says he held up meaning me bill held up
a disc once again calling it a
circle aha he's saying that oh do i have
one oh
let's see if i can get it
i showed something like this okay
i hope that's not too bright let me turn
it around same brightness okay i showed
something like this i'm saying that this
is a circle okay
a roundish thing flat earth
circle and this guy says he shows a this
is he says that's a circle that's not a
circle
uh too lengthy an answer so what i'm
going to do i'm going to
put it as the subject matter of
wednesday because
apparently people don't have the
slightest idea what a circle is what a
square is what a triangle is
we got to get these people up to speed
with basic geometry okay they need to
learn the
abcs of geometry they need to learn
kindergarten geometry
right now these folks have no idea what
a circle is
and so that'll be the subject matter of
on wednesday
next time we'll see you there bye